Ocean Gate shouldn't have been doing
what it was doing I think that's pretty
clear I wish I had been more vocal about
that
[Music]
and there it is you're looking right
down into the curve of the a deck level
[Music]
a lot of them got together and wrote a
letter
to uh to Ocean Gate and said you have to
certify you cannot take people down it's
irresponsible and it could lead to
catastrophe literally the word
catastrophe is in the letter
oh
I never believed in that technology of
wound carbon fiber you know loud
filament
cylinder cylindrical Hull I thought it
was a horrible idea
we all knew that the danger was
delamination and and Progressive failure
over time with microscopic water Ingress
and fatigue
what they call cycling fatigue and we
knew that if the sub passage pressure
test it wasn't going to fail on the
first dive
it might fail on dive seven or I don't I
don't know what they're at you know
but it's going to fail over time
which is Insidious you don't get that
with steel or titanium
[Music]
thank you
discovered the Talco of the Titan
submersible approx imately
you know sometimes people get go fever
you know and look we celebrate
Innovation right but you shouldn't be
using an experimental vehicle for for
paying passengers that aren't themselves
deep ocean engineers
foreign